yeah come on welcome to the video
playing culture from France lots of
first-time opponents culture Jack yeah
the Catalan Bhogle a five I can try
Queenie seven that serve a variety sake
let's see what happens here Knight f3
probably or Bishop g2 okay this is Jack
an interesting line alrighty might take
with a night not about pre moving yeah I
night eggs I might want to play d65
without 96 yeah here this is a funny
situation now 93 oh interesting is doing
something totally different okay
a three okay no no d phi or not I
playing this very very quickly which
means here is one of those guys who
wants to play insta moves all the time
all you really knows what he's doing one
of the two okay if I take and go e5 is
this is this good is this good take
Quinn take e 5 d 5 v 4 takes takes moon
not sure I can take you far l can play
'if i've also immediately de 95 maybe I
got a good development
but again let's let's keep it simple
Queen takes a 5 g 5 ok nice he wants to
do this ok maybe I can start with this
move so night eggs I just win the
default porn at e3 as a move that I'd
like to provoke of course maybe getting
some dark squared some light squared
weaknesses in whites camp and this is
surprising I thought that no e5 should
be should be quite good sd2 is hanging
you know like de nighty Knight takes
Queen takes he cannot cancel because D
to Hanks so I thought that this would be
a pretty favorable version of all that
and b2 hangs so why does some white is
not very well developed
no not so easy know what is he doing be
to Hanks d2 is always an issue Quincy to
Bishop f5 does not look like a loose
solution yeah the question is yeah
version of this is Hamlet right to take
or not to take it's not not exactly
Hamlet butter hmm that's a very
attractive position now I wonder if I
can maybe if I take it castles and I
take d two voices it's just like
suicidal due to my background on give
not that this is probably really good
queen bee to quincy seven fish of age
three maybe Queen B seven hmm i don't
really see why I shouldn't take castles
I can really take on the tool ya hear
there are funny lines honey lions but I
cannot go here
hmm we are queen bee seven looks looks
really annoying
and the development is excellent but hmm
okay I must move I must make a move
Queen B seven now nah this is not going
to work i don't think so look too well
looked at you rook cake I was him I can
take on youtube with the Queen what am i
doing no no from this position no I
can't play anything here and we know I
know stupid is that roop d to know I can
just play Queen e5 or anything he's
totally she is totally busted I know no
I know I'm just an exchange down for zip
and pip after this game no oh man yeah
okay jack okay i will play on a bit I
mean he played this fair share of weird
moves before maybe he's doing some more
but objectively speaking I'm just toast
here
threatening h3 winning the bishop oh
it's overlooking that a way to not not
pre moving too much now yeah this is
actually turning again in my favor I
think
well I don't know but at least I'm not
busted anymore which was definitely the
case before Jack 26 seconds this looks
like a real issue my trading Queens is
not really good but I want the simpler
to pace a place situation here I can
just play quicker moves
yeah I get in get to see to threatening
93 now jack is running right into that
it's funky yeah I'm winning this this
still we had despised us this totally
totally cilia Jacob Jonah on d to check
check check check mate yeah I was what
what kind of idiot i am i am rook takes
you to a file form for the big the big
thing is I can't do whatever I mean here
like after this threatening mate and he
has no move really I have rook c8 coming
and I'm just so far better developed
that why this is minus 2.2 the comp the
comp evil yeah this position is just a
it's just more more comfortable for
black and I actually during the game I
already suspected what the computer is
now giving that you should do this which
is not great but at least it's not what
is not getting clobbered yeah after that
I'm just much better better especially
for even
Bishop g4 now he cannot Castle just
excellent okay this he took the ship
g-form this is only a slight edge but I
was a bit a bit surprised that he went
Quincy one I thought that you should
take after which i didn't i didn't see
him actually I had a very funny funny
thing in my at first I was thinking I
could do this actually which looks
totally I had this this kind of
variation in mind why it takes um this
is even defending the thing it's just
totally got to kick it also takes the
eight so this line was so stupid so this
is what what we did and I thought he
should take probably here and then we
continue from there this is just slight
advantage from black it's not like I'm
winning like a queen bee three Queenie
seven and she can hang on with Queen III
which is not nice but at least he's not
not beaten quickly then this after Queen
e5 should just use this is a total brain
fart here completely completely strange
guy can take with the Queen and resins
guarantee a white of course just once it
was giving away that and now now somehow
ignored their age three idea with this
check and here the the MV I'm better
again but I'm it's not a good idea to
really exchange Queens because his King
is potentially more vulnerable but i
only had 27 seconds I wasn't sure I
wanted to play quick move so this is why
I went for this objectively this is not
so great yeah but ok blundered it away
to a torn us okay we had game thanks for
watching